[Music]
can we
and which committee members are here and
the officers who will be supporting us
today
um thank you chair um in the meeting
room today
we have councillors william armitage
jane barry
andrew cooper mark foster carol huckabee
moe potts allen powell tracy reader
jackie ridgeway kathy rouse diana ruff
and ross shipman as members of the
planning committee also in attendance we
have councillors
charlotte cupid and heather liggett who
are speaking today as ward members
in addition we have a number of members
of the public who have registered to
speak we have john shaw
kevin bush helen lyman judy wetton and
the agent for the application
john dickinson members of
staff who are with us today is we have a
number of members of the governance team
which include alan maher who will be the
clerk for the meeting and myself who
will facilitate the meeting with
caliber we have the head of planning at
richard pasell
the planning manager adrian kirkham
and phil slater who is the um
case officer for this application and a
solicitor in the room gym fields and
thank you chair thank you as explained
earlier today we have a protocol
in place for meeting in this way which i
would now like the meeting facilitator
to read again
thank you chair so um in the same way
that we did for this morning session
all members of the committee are asked
to keep their cameras on
throughout the duration of the meeting
um
voting will be done by roll call so this
will be exactly the same as we do in the
chamber
and and i will call out names in
alphabetical order and if you can
clearly indicate
with a voice command either for against
or abstained
for speaking today if you'd like to
raise your hand the chair will hopefully
be able to see that from the chamber
from her screens
if for any reason she is unable to see
you you can use
the chat function and request to speak
um and i will also
put prompts with closed captioning in
front of you just to
make you aware that we've captured your
wish to speak or to
communicate anything you need to know
during the meeting thank you chad
thank you are there any apologies for
absence this afternoon
our councilor peter elliott chair thank
you
um okay so we're on to the last
application of the sea this afternoon
declarations of interest
oh sorry declarations of interest are
there any for this afternoon's meeting
and i have been received here and then
following on from that is the minutes of
the last meeting
um is everybody happy with the minutes
of the last meeting have you all read
those
yeah just have a show of hands
that looks approved joe thank you
is there a remover for these to be
accepted
i'll move them chair and everyone's
happy with them that's fine thank you
the main business of this afternoon is
the final application
and consideration of the planning
application however before we do this
i'd like the clerk to explain for the
benefit of members speakers and the
public who are watching you on youtube
how it will be dealt with yes thank you
sorry yes thank you sir this is the
procedure for considering the
application
at the meeting the chair will introduce
the application
and ask the planning officers to refer
members to any late comments or updates
received
since the agenda was issued the late
items agenda supplement has been
published
on the council's website and the link
has been sent to committee members
the planning officers will then give a
brief presentation
setting out the application plans and
photographs from the site
the screen showing this presentation
will be shared with those attending the
meeting
they can also be seen on the council's
website through its youtube channel
following on from this the chair will
ask each of the speakers
any ward members first followed by
objectors then the applicants or their
agent
to speak to the committee each speaker
will have three minutes to perform with
their views
using the conferencing facility
there will be a reminder given by the
clerk when 30 seconds remain
at the end of the speakers three minutes
members of the committee
will have the opportunity to ask the
speakers questions if necessary
to clarify any points that they have
made
when we have heard from all the speakers
on the application the chair will open
up the meeting for debate by the
committee
and determination by a vote
a note for speakers after your
contribution
you may leave the virtual meeting room
if you choose to remain
then please mute your microphone and
turn off your camera
you will not be allowed to participate
further in the meeting from that point
as you're aware this meeting is being
live streamed
the council will make a recording for
purposes of preparing the minutes
once these minutes have been approved by
the committee and this recording will be
deleted
please note however that others may also
record the live stream
from the internet thank you chair
thank you we'll move to the afternoon's
application which is ned
forward slash 1900 335
regarding hallfield gate lane at
sherland
over to the planning officer
thank you chair and there's a number of
uh updates
um first i'd like to refer members to
the late comments report
there's also been one email received
last night from a resident at fernley
however it has not raised any new issues
not covered in the report
we've also received an email from
residents of hawfield gate lane
that raises the following objections in
summary
number one sherland historic context the
hamlet
of sherland appears in the doomsday
manuscript this naturally beautiful
and rural setting is immediately
adjacent a conservation area
two proposed development and
sustainability
there is nothing sustainable about the
proposed development
and the residents won't be employed
locally therefore will need to travel
by car supply of brownfield size is
sustainable
and meets the requirements of the neddc
climate change plan number three any ddc
climate change plan 2019-2030
the proposed development fails to meet
the stated targets within the neddc
climate change plan number four
wildlife habitat and local immunity
the local history landscape natural
habitats
and wildlife combine to become a
valuable
local amenity enjoyed by residents and
visitors
alike in summary the residents of
sherland do not
want or need this new development
hundreds of new houses already being
built in the village
and we've also had uh a phone call from
a mr john robinson
who was who has just returned from
holiday and wishes that his presence
is registered to committee and he does
not wish to speak
he also wishes it to be known that he is
a naturist
and that the application would be
intimidating and an impact on his
privacy
we could turn to the presentation please
nikki
thank you
put up the air the first slide that's
great
i set out in the report the site lies
outside of the defined settlement
development limit for sherland
and lies within open countryside
proposals would provide
20 affordable housing on site and
section 106 contributions
to primary and secondary education there
are no technical objections from the
statutory council teas
on the slide this slide shows the
application site
shaded in the center of the screen to
the north
is hall field gate lane to the west is
the hallfield gate conservation area
to the south is sherland golf club and
to the east
lies pits lane grab the next slide
please
thank you this show was the red line
application site
boundary the shaded area running north
to south is proposed as a biodiversity
enhancement corridor and open space
slide through please
thank you this shows the proposed access
arrangements
the development will be served by a
single point of access on horfield gate
lane
the trees that front hortonville gate
lane are protected by true preservation
order
the access proposals include an 0.75
metre build out
on the southern side of the lane to
provide sight lines clear of existing
trees
proposals include an amendment to the
existing parking bays on the north side
of hawfield gate lane
to ensure dimensions are maintained and
also the relocation of the bus stop
on the north side at next eye please
this slide shows the indicative layout
to the north is a new access onto
horfield gate lane
the layout provides a gap between the
development and the conservation area to
the west
whilst providing a continuation of
properties fronted onto horfield gate
lane
in the northwest corner a bio diversity
enhancement
open space corridor is shown running
north to south
between the two fields and down the
existing tree line
to the south the scheme is generally
outward facing towards the golf course
to the north the site is adjacent to the
rear gardens of houses on horfield gate
lane
and additional planting is proposed to
the rear of the houses with the shorter
regards
and to provide an additional buffer next
life please
this photo is taken from byron street
opposite the site
and is looking towards the conservation
area the trees on the opposite side
are the ones protected by true
preservation order and next libraries
this vote was looking east and shows
proposed access point
where the current access is located and
also shows for
more of the protected trees and next
slide please
this photo is taken at the site entrance
looking east
the trees in the photo would be retained
and form
part of the biodiversity corridor the
main development will be beyond the
trees
next slide please
this is a view looking south from
horrorville gate lane
this is where the properties front in
the lane will be cited
closest to the conservation area so next
slide please
so another view from hawfil gate lane
looking back towards the conservation
area
the new house will be located in this
part of the field post and rail fence
roughly shows the location of the
proposed new access
next liar please
this is a view from the footpath of pit
lane to the east of the site
this shows the main area of the
development to the north
and the right hand side of the
photograph are the rear gardens of
houses on horfield gate lane
next slide please it's a further
photo from the footpath on lane
the next slide please
this is a view from the pit lane
footpath looking northeast
towards the existing houses on
horfilgate lane
application site will be to the left of
the hedgerow in the photo
next slide please thank you
now this is a view from the footpath to
the south west of the site
uh photo is looking roughly north east
and
again shows the houses on horfield gate
lane development will be in the fields
to the rear of these houses
next slide please another photo from the
footpath looking north
east you can see the church in the
background and the golf course can be
seen
in the top left of the photo no sorry
top right of the photo
this is a more distant view taken from
the footpath
which runs towards the golf course
houses on whole field gate lane can be
seen in the distance
and the final slides photo again looking
northeast from the footpath
development will be largely sighted
beyond the three trees in the center of
the photo
and that's the end of the presentation
thank you chair
thank you do we have any questions for
the planning officer at this stage
wow okay
we'll move on to the first speaker then
and it's the ward member counselor
charlotte coupet
hello councillor if you'd like to
introduce yourself and then it's three
minutes thank you
thank you chair um so i'm councillor
charlotte cupid and i'm speaking against
the
application today um i'm here today as a
ward member to highlight the damage this
application would cause
as an unsustainable development in what
is clearly open countryside
as you can see even just from the maps
in your pack this proposed site doesn't
in any way relate to
or infill with the main part of sherland
it would quite clearly be outside the
established settlement line and
development limit
visibly marked by the currently linear
housing pattern boundary
this area at the moment is clearly rural
open green fields and countryside with
far-reaching views across the valley
and vice versa from the surrounding
fields and from as far away as amber
valley this area can clearly be seen
and marks out the prevailing rural
character of our district
in a similar way at the bottom end of
the application site lies the
highlighted hallfield gates conservation
area
with several listed and historically
important buildings
whilst the application have been amended
to slightly move away from this area
it's still the case that this proposed
development would have a significant
adverse impact on the historic setting
of these buildings and on the
conservation area previous appeal
decisions on smaller applications near
this conservation area
have recognized that a main
characteristic of it is the open fields
and gardens
reflective of the surrounding open
countryside need the october 2019
conservation consultant comments on this
application
recognises the importance of the
remaining open fields in this
application to the rural setting of the
conservation area
and considers these views as important
just from the consul
consultants conservation opinions they
consider the whole field directly to the
east should remain as open space
whereas that field is clearly still
marked out for quite a few houses
in the proposals uh cpre derbyshire also
recognize and support all these concerns
and have also strongly objected
plans on the wider basis and i quote
that the proposed development would
irreversibly change the essential rural
quality
of the south side of sherland and the
character of sherland would be changed
from village to suburb
therefore particularly given the
development clearly underway on the
other side of the road
for 92 houses this application would
overload the area
and cannot be considered as sustainable
even just from an affordable housing
point of view
the council's housing strategy officer
has stated and i quote
sherland is a small village in which
there have been a number of developments
in recent times
so there is not currently a high demand
here and at the current time it is not
seen as a suitable site even for
affordable housing provision
so as a final point it may already be
clear i'm sure it will be to you that
the number of resident speakers who are
following
you but i also want to highlight the
significant number of written objections
and the many people currently watching
the live stream this demonstrates i
think the strength of local feelings
that development would saturate and
exhaust the village of sherland
and destroy cherished countryside so i
hope you listen to these concerns and
refuse this speculative application
thank you chair thank you
are there any questions at this stage
thank you thank you councillor and the
next speaker
is councillor heather liggett good
afternoon
um heather liggett speaking against this
development
on may the 9th 2013 wielden's were given
permission to build
90-plus houses between the a61 and
hallfield gate lane
why was it that they were not allowed to
build without 2x
two entrances these development
this development at this development is
for the same amount of housing
the wheels and development was split
into two the east exit onto the a61 the
south exit onto lilac way
which comes out onto half field eight
lane only a few yards from the proposed
new development
entrance this will mean an increase of
approximately 300 more cars
using what as the name suggests is a
lane
the so-called walk to school from the
back of the development would come out
across the fairway onto the golf course
how safe is that for children the teeing
off will be straight towards
unclean children this is a village
the infrastructure can't cope our
nearest doctors is at stoneroom
part of the staffer group which is
possibly closing
at least a six week wait for phone lines
even if you need one because of medical
needs a buzzer for accidents
alzheimer's etc sewers bursting
14 times in the last four and a half
years
sanitary towels etc feet from where the
new houses will be beat
that will be built at the east side of
the estate
surface water flooding which has
increased since the wilderness
development
even though we were assured it wouldn't
gas cottage has been flooded right
through
twice it's only 75 meters from where the
new houses will be built
the school is full so is the school in
the next village of westington
new residents on the wilderness estate
are taking their children to truck's
christ school this is before the
wilderness estate is even finished being
built
mine sold and lived in i am also very
concerned
about safety from golf balls we collect
around 50 a year from our field
right next to the proposed site gas
cottage has suffered so many crack tiles
mr subby has had to replace his utility
roof this year
his father was also hit on the head by a
golf ball some years ago
and suffered strokes and memory loss
afterwards to put housing
right up to a golf course is madness
people wouldn't be safe in their own
gardens
we simply do not need or want any more
houses in our village
the infrastructure cannot and will not
come
thank you for listening thank you
are there any questions
okay moving on to the next speaker
the first one i've on my list is the mr
john shaw
hello mr shaw if you'd like to unmute
your microphone
if you'd like to introduce yourself and
then you have three minutes
yeah my name is john shaw i've lived in
sherlin
since 1953. between 1964 and 67
i worked for george shipman who actually
lived in oakville gate hall
he was the main contractor for
subsidence work
for the ncb i worked as an apprentice
joiner and worked on subsidence in
sherland
including official gate lane to the
north
and the south side the work involved
is indoors windows making good to
plasterway
et cetera sherlin was quite badly
by subsidence and one house in streter
lane
only two fields away north side of
oakville gate lane
had to be totally rebuilt
i also remember the open cast in
sherland
and the whole area was devastated by
this by
the south and the west side
i remember larger walls where coal was
extracted
it's taken 60 years to reestablish
itself
now the edge rolls and wildlife for
flourishing
mining was a big party sherlin and the
large coal extraction beneath the ground
could cause big problems for the new
build
i'm also concerned about the traffic
from the bill
this will cause problems for maybe a
year two year three years
every plant machinery deliveries country
dharma stone you name it there's a lot
of traffic
needed to build one house and he's
applying for 90.
the exit also leading onto the a61 is
quite notorious for
for locals we use it readily it's a
difficult junction
for large vehicles
you as you come up from the south of
the a61 turning onto off your gate lane
if you're in a large vehicle
the site of view is quite obstructive
i know this because i've got a large
vehicle myself and it's difficult
especially if there's a car
or a lorry wanting to come out onto the
a61
with the traffic involved in the new
build will cause endless problems
i totally disagree with the planning
application that has been made by mr
speed
with all its complications once the
green lantern
has gone the greenland has gone
it has gone i urge this committee
to reflect on my notes and reject the
application
thank you thank you are there any
questions
no thank you very much mr shaw
the next speaker i have listed is the mr
ian north
mr north if you'd like to unmute
yourself and state your name
good afternoon my name is ian north and
i'm a resident on holifield gateway
hallfield gate lane is a small but busy
village road
the recent increase of housing to the
north of the lane has made it
increasingly dangerous
to drive along it is effectively a
single lane road
because the residents on the north side
of the road have no option
but to park their vehicles on it
therefore
the addition of a further 90 houses to
the south of the
lane would almost certainly double the
amount of traffic used in the lane
the increase of vehicles on the plane
would undoubtedly cause a great deal of
stress
danger and almost certainly damage and
injury or worse to the residents of the
lane
and those who use it i would therefore
ask you to
consider the effect these 90 houses and
the massive increase of vehicles would
have on the already suffering
residents of whole field wholefield
gateway and the whole population of
sherland
we must also remember that the wildlife
of the surrounding area
will most certainly be negatively
affected also
thank you very much thank you
are there any questions
and the next one on the list is mr kevin
bush
good afternoon good afternoon you'd like
to introduce yourself and then it's
three minutes
i'm kevin bush and i'm a resident who is
objecting to the proposal
and i want to talk about the local plan
in both the previous and emerging local
plans this area falls outside of the
settlement development limit as
determined by the council policy lc1
which covers land allocated for
development
in my view the fact there has been a gap
in the effective period of the previous
plan and the implementation of the new
cannot mean that there were left
completely at the mercy of speculative
development in the other walk of life
due changes in legislation mean that
current law is suspended
whilst new laws are drafted in any event
we are in the very last phase of
consultation for the new local plan
as it has such a late stage with only
areas to the north of the district still
subject to discussion
with no further consultation plan for
the area in question
it is reasonable to expect that the
provisions of the new plan are given
full weight in this case
in particular the housing supply
estimates for sureland have already been
met
and exceeded for the life of the new
plan
commissions have already been granted on
the allocated sites for sherland in the
draft local plan for around 130 houses
another 90 here would lead to a near 70
oversupply of housing against projected
need
it is a fact that the applicant has made
a number of attempts to have this area
of land included in the new plan
and on every occasion the planet
inspector has rejected the proposal
it would be quite wrong to allow this
application to be backdoored in
contravention of what is clearly the
considered view of the inspectorate
after a very lengthy period of
consultation with the widest range of
consultees
the tone of the officers report in
general seems to play down the way to
the emerging plan
this leads on to my next point planning
policies sdc3
and gs6 are clear developments that
cause significant harm to the open
character of the land
loss of amenity or which form of
prominent intrusion to open countries
should not be permitted
the land is agricultural and forms part
of the open rural landscape
the officer's report does not give due
regard to these factors in my opinion
and underestimates the negative impact
of this development
finally part of the argument for
approval refers to the land being
adjacent to existing settlement
every piece of green space in this
country or anywhere else is adjacent to
a settlement
that is why i use the decisions that are
made within the framework of the local
plan
if we have to protect the countryside
from speculative proposals
proposals that irreversibly damage
precious and increasingly scarce
rural immunity thank you
thank you are there any questions
thank you the next speaker i have on my
list is helen linen
hello well good afternoon if you'd like
to introduce yourself and then it's
three minutes thank you
okay the hell in line and i live on half
hill gate lane i'm
objecting to the proposal i wish to
highlight the traffic issues on horfield
gate lane
the additional traffic from the existing
developments and this proposed
development is unsustainable
this will cause problems for all
residents hall field gate lane under
joining roads
paulville gate lane is already busy and
was used by many motorists as a wrap run
and a cut through in both directions the
traffic surveys accompanied this
application were written in 2017
prior to the additional traffic that has
been created by new housing both in
sherland
and the surrounding areas we have not
yet felt the full
impact of the housing development to the
north of warfield gateway
as it is still on development so that
coupled with this proposal would lead to
traffic
chaos each new home is likely to have at
least one car
probably two all to be used for
commuting or the school run which is due
to lack
which due to the lack of places in
sherlin school this is likely to be
outside of the village
with this and the other local
developments is estimated to develop to
be well over 300 additional car journeys
will be made
per day along the lane
while the junctions at either end of the
road are stated in the highways report
to
being fit for purpose i can only say
this is far from the case in practice
it is quite common already to have to
queue to join the a61
and the speeding traffic at the velcro
road junction is also an issue
when time to join from horfield gate
lane
as a local resident i feel the issues
have been overlooked
through lack of local knowledge for a
distance of about 150 meters
the road is effectively single track due
to parked cars it is not uncommon to see
vehicles mounting the pavements to avoid
cueing
putting pedestrians at great risk this
single track section lies between the
proposed site exit
and the a61 increasing the danger to
pedestrians
the applicant suggests that 80 percent
of traffic leaving this proposed
development will travel towards the a61
refuse collection and some deliveries
can bring this road to a total
standstill along this section
this road is not designed for existing
volumes of traffic never mind increased
volumes
while few incidents are reported to the
police it's not unusual to witness
accidents
one writing off my neighbor's car other
incidents ranging from clipped mirrors
road rage and speed
these incidents can only increase the
proposed increase in traffic
the main bus stop on a61 will be 800
meters away
sherlin school if places were to be
available to one kilometer away
both of these distances make it more
likely that any new residents
will use their cars adding to the
problem
i would urge the committee to refuse
this application
thank you thank you are there any
questions
no the next speaker i have is judy
wetton
if you'd like to introduce yourself and
you've got three minutes hello
my name i live in high is
anymore
try again can you hear me now we can
hear you
i want to talk about safety i'm sure
that the
planning committee and its officers
would agree that before an
application is approved every element of
public safety must be considered
unfortunately this is not true where
this this
development is concerned unfortunately
the most basic need for children to have
a safe route from school
has not been considered so if children
leave the
proposed housing estate by the only exit
that exists on the until hallfield gate
lane
they must exit onto a road with no
pavement
children will be left standing on the
side of the road waiting for a breaking
traffic
before they could cross to a pavement on
the opposite side
this lane is very busy narrow and
dangerous
conversely the children could use the
back route
from the estate by a public footpath
suggested
and described very eloquently by the
applicants
the first challenge for the children
would be to actually
get onto the public footpath which runs
across the golf course
to do so they must trespass onto the
gold course itself
when they would doubtful to be greeted
with hostility from any golfers
as this path actually crosses the
fairway
with some look the children may avoid
being seriously injured by a golf ball
following the path the children will
then climb a style and enter a field
in which youtube to highland cattle with
their legendary
enormous horns roam freely at the moment
the huge beasts are on loan to a local
farmer
but they only tells me that they could
return it anytime
the next obstacle would be pit lane dark
overgrown narrow road
leading to sherland golf club not wide
enough for cars
to pass each other vehicles reverse and
maneuver around blind bends causing
chaos
since this is a private unadopted road
vehicles are not bound by the rules of
insurance
licensing or even driving as they would
be on a public road
summarize from this housing development
there will be no safe way for children
to walk to school
being elected as a councillor is a huge
responsibility
because the general public expects the
decisions taken on their behalf by
councillors will be fair logical and
reasonable
and will reflect and respond to the
wishes of local residents
i would respectfully ask members of the
planning committee to think
about the safety of these children about
these children
when considering the application
the people of sherlon will see no
benefit if commission is granted
in fact the only person to benefit from
this proposal
is a multi-millionaire who lives in his
own manner house many miles from
sherland
and who recently sold half through
gateway well over a million pounds
please vote against this application
thank you
thank you are there any questions
no thank you our next speaker is alan
coltrane
hello hello if you'd like to introduce
yourself
you have three minutes okay uh my name
is alan cocaine
i'm a resident on the south side of
hawfield gate lane
i want to talk about uh the history of
the area
and the sustainability of this
development
to understand this setting we have to
understand the history
sherland is listed in the doomsday book
st leonard's church dates from 12 26
sherlin manor existed on the site where
maniform is today
maps published in the 1840s show the
field boundaries and hedgerows
much as they are today it is unchanged
the historic and rural setting is
adjacent to a conservation area
and the centuries old sheeply the
historical context
is enhanced by the wider landscape which
incorporates amber valley
wingfield manor and the ancient roman
road
all of this combines to describe a
historical landscape
and the setting that provides a valuable
local immunity that is accessed by the
local
network of footpaths
the application to build 90 dwellings is
not a sustainable solution and is
completely out of context
with the described setting the
application is in direct conflict with
eight of the sustainable targets
shown in the authority's own climate
change plan
there is no additional infrastructure
there are no extra schools
shops health care leisure or child care
facilities
children from the wielding development
are already being driven to cry at
school
because there are no places at sherlon
primary school for employment
residents will be traveling by car to
derby nottingham manfield chesterfield
sheffield
and beyond they will put more pressure
on the existing road network
particularly clawfield gate lane
alfredton clay cross and okathawk
the extra car journeys will increase
pollution and they will impact on the
safety of the residents
the daily occurrences of road rage and
vehicles driving along the pedestrian
pavements
of whole field game lane will increase
and this is a school route for local
children
i don't think this is acceptable
the authority already has enough land to
meet its target for new builds
in addition the sustainable development
report published by the campaign to
protect rural england
shows there is enough suitable
brownfield land available in england
for more than one million homes over
eighteen thousand sites and twenty six
thousand day
hectares there is no need to build on
this land
i urge you to do something
do something sustainable the landscape
is also a natural wildlife habitat
the hairs badges hedgehogs panels
buzzards and much more
don't get a mention in this application
several of these
are under protection in the uk
this is an ancient beautiful and rural
setting that provides a wildlife habitat
and an extremely valuable local immunity
that is widely enjoyed
by the local residents the development
is out of context for the setting
it's not needed wanted or supported by
the residents
i urge you to stop this application
thank you
thank you are there any questions
no right i've heard richard salvi
is in my next speaker yes chair i shall
be reading this for
uh mr and mrs southie as they can't make
the meeting
thank you okay my concern regarding the
proposed development
on land to the south of hullfield gate
lane
sherland in derbyshire is related to
surface water
and flooding our garden has flooded many
times
on our house twice in recent years
making house insurance an extremely
expensive commodity
under the heading technical
considerations 4.0
claims which state the site does not
fall within an area designated
as being at risk from flooding or false
it also claims that the risk is low and
the proposed development will be located
in flood zone 1 and that it will not
displace flood water in the
1 in 100 year event and therefore
no flood water storage mitigation
measures are proposed
if this application is conditionally
approved without flood water storage
and our property floods again i will
take this personally
and hold any ddc liable
and take legal action as we were assured
that we would not be affected by surface
water
or flooding from the ongoing fox hollies
development
on main road sherland which has a flood
water air flood storage
facility which is totally inadequate as
muddy
and clay-colored water from that
development is still reaching us down
here
and troubling us when we were reassured
that it would not
i reiterate we cannot take any more
surface water
coming our way the design and access
statement
relating to the alfield gate proposed
development
clearly indicates that it is their
intention
to direct surface water down to us
for this reason and purely this reason
and no other we objected planning
permission being granted
the design and access statement is full
of untruths regarding flood risk
and that's from mr a southie and mrs jm
southie
thank you chair thank you
as we've got no one to answer questions
and the last speaker i've got on my list
is the agent john
dickinson
hello mr dickinson if you'd like to
introduce yourself and then it's three
minutes
good afternoon chairman members i'm john
dickinson of wyg
thank you sorry can you hear me
yes we can thank you i'm john dickinson
of wyg the planning agent for the
applicant
the proposed development of 90 houses
would comprise a sustainable urban
extension to the south west of sherland
the office's report confirms that the
local plan only made provision for
housing
up to 2011 and safe housing policies
dealing with settlement development
limits
and housing targets cannot be relied
upon
in addition the emerging local plan is
unadopted and
can only be given limited weight at this
stage
the national planning policy framework
confirms that decisions should apply a
presumption in favor of sustainable
development
which in this case means granting
permission unless policies in the
framework that protect areas or assets
of particular importance provide a clear
reason for refusal
or any adverse impact of doing so would
significantly and demonstrably outweigh
the benefits
when assessed against the policies in
the framework taken as a whole
the officer's report notes that the
scheme is broadly sustainable
and not detrimental to the landscape
character of the district or the wider
countryside
with any impact being localized and
limited
the office's report recognizes that the
scheme will provide significant
social benefits with the delivery of
housing
including 20 affordable homes and
section 106 contributions to education
the economic benefits of the scheme
include jobs and spend during the
construction phase
and spend by occupants of the houses in
the local economy
along with benefits to the council
including the new homes bonus
the officer's report notes that the
scheme is considered to preserve the
character of the nearby conservation
area
and any localized harm is offset by the
public benefits of the crew
the officer's report recognizes that the
scheme has the potential to offer goods
design
that would be in keeping with the
character and appearance of the
surrounding area
and that it would not result in any
detrimental impact
upon the privacy or immunity of
neighboring residents
in relation to console t responses there
are no technical objections
or matters weighing against the scheme
and the officer's report confirms that
following consultation with the highways
authority the scheme would not have a
detrimental impact
on highway safety we welcome the
conclusion of the officer's report that
the scheme accords with the policies of
the development plan
and their recommendation that subject to
the completion 50 seconds remain
section 106 agreements and conditions
that permission should be granted
in this respect we would request that
members approve the application
in line with the officer's
recommendation thank you
thank you are there any questions
counselor shipment thank you chair um i
just wondered if mr dickinson could
explain
to the planning committee what
sustainable benefits the development has
because all the things that he's
mentioned such as
you know the new homes bonus and
people buying the house they're all
things you could apply to any single
development that comes before this
committee
there's nothing i don't see that's
specific to this development which has
given us a sustainable benefit to the
people of sherland or the wider area so
i just wondered if there's anything that
he had
that was additional to what he's told us
already to to offer this as a
sustainable development because
so far i've heard absolutely nothing
which would convince me that this is
sustainable
thank you
thank you do you have any response
thank you well well the officers have
carefully considered the
socio-economic benefits and
during the construction phase it's
anticipated that
a proportion of the jobs will be taken
up by
local people as well as those who may
travel from further afield
in addition they'll be um spend in the
local economy
during this construction phase of the
scheme
and once residents occupy the houses
they will also contribute to the local
economy
by their spend in the area
council armitage thank you chair
uh you say that uh
the uh it's sustainable but
how can you make out that it's
sustainable when there are no school
uh places in the primary school
and the doctors uh are overstretched
i mean perhaps could you you could
answer this question
for me
thank you um officers consulted with
derbyshire county council and
they've requested a financial
contribution for
primary and secondary school places
which
totals almost eight hundred thousand
pounds
which they would allocate for
improvements at
um schools in
in the locality um also the offices
consulted with the
healthcare trust and
they did not request any financial
contributions
um in relation to this scheme
thank you thank you
any further questions
thank you
are there any questions to the planning
officers before we move
on
no okay
so we're now going into the final part
of our process
of our discussions of regarding what
we've just heard
and what we think and what we wish to
decide but before we go any further i'd
like uh clark to remind us about motions
yes thank you chair uh please bear in
mind members
that a motion must be moved and seconded
before a vote is taken
an amendment to a motion is moved and
seconded
then that amendment will be voted on
first
if a motion is to be moved which goes
against the officer recommendations
then the member who has moved the motion
must give the reasons for doing so
the reasons for moving a motion against
officer recommendations
should comprise the relevant planning
issues
and be supported by evidence as
necessary
if a motion to reject officer
recommendations fails
in other words it is not passed that
doesn't mean that say that the
recommendations themselves are
automatically approved
rather you will need to take a positive
decision through a further motion
in favor of the recommendations or
another course of action
this will need to be approved by the
committee through another vote
thank you joe thank you councillor
armitage did you wish to say something
uh i'd like to uh just to make one or
two
comments uh on this and give some
reasons
i uh i move that we go against
officers recommendation uh i've got
uh if we look at gs1
uh about this sustainability
uh it's not sustainable uh the
school places are very limited in the
doctor's
surgery if we go to uh gs6
it's outside the settlement development
area it's in open countryside
and be detrimental to wildlife and one
thing in another
and any one landscape
it will certainly be a detrimental
effect
on the greenfield sites that we've got
if we go then to uh it's right next to
the conservation area the whole field
gate
and that will be in contravention to
be 11.
the housing supply it's been noted that
we've got a seven year housing supply
and
it's been met so as far as i'm concerned
i'll go against officer's recommendation
and turn this one down and the reasons
are the ones that i've given
thank you councillor adrian kirkham
sorry
adrian you're mute well there's you said
yeah
um i'm happy to come in now i do know
council shipment had his hands
raised jam have to come in now or have
to counsel the ship and whatever
whatever you'd like
should we wait to see what council
shipment has to say and then you can
answer them all
yes chet councillor
thank you chair um i'm just going back
to what um i think it was mr bush said
in his comments earlier that um
it's not right that we're adopting
things even though the previous plan is
out of date and the new one's not been
adopted because actually the
national planning policy framework
specifies
that we can make reference to the
previous one and we should give
especially given the stage that the
current ones have we should be giving it
significant way because it's in its
advanced stages
and therefore i would say that
i don't believe this uh development
offers a solution to any of the problems
raised in today by multiple
people that have raised concerns about
this development um
i think uh residents who live here would
be heading
in three directions for employment they
would be going north to chesterfield up
the a61 which we know is a bad road then
we're going south to alfreton
which we know is a bad road or they
would be going east towards m1
junction 28 or 29 which junction 28-29
is one of the longest stretches of m1
and as soon as that's closed off it
causes unbelievable stress on the road
networks in that area
so i think we need to take that into
account when we're looking at adding
additional stress
onto the a61 and this section of
northeast derbyshire
um i would also i would also like to add
that the county council explained that
the local primary school at sherland is
full this is what this county council
has said in their comments it's full
and therefore there's no there's no
scope to expand
the primary school at sherland what they
would have to do is they'd have to
allocate the section 106 money that's
generated from this development to churn
the primary school at wooly moore or
even worse in my mind to give it to
outside the district to a secondary
school in alfred
now that doesn't make any sense to me
and to say that's sustainable
is bonkers to be quite honest with you
um
so we can't do much about the approve
the already approved developments along
the a61
but as a planning committee it's our
responsibility to ensure that we're not
adding additional stress
onto this section of road um and i would
like to second uh council armature's
motion to reject
the officer's uh recommendations because
i don't think that they've
we have this i feel like we have this
same discussion even when i've watched
planning committees previously to me
being on here
that we we talk as though the plan
national policy
policy framework shouldn't be giving
weight to the existing
or emerging plans and it's just totally
wrong to suggest that
um and i think we can reject it under
many parts of the national poll
planning policy framework the one about
we should be giving
we should be giving um weight to the
emerging plan
um which i believe is 48 a if i'm if i'm
right
and at this 49 a and b
again talking about cumulative
development um
and it talks about the emerging of the
advanced stage of the
emerging plan and i think the um
additional to what council amateurs have
said
and the effects it would have on the
locality in sherland and the
how unsustainable this development is i
think it should be rejected on those
on those reasons thank you
thank you okay adrian if you'd like to
come back on those comments
yes sir thank you chad i just like to
address um some points as well which i'd
uh ask members to exercise great caution
in place and wait on and then
come back to those which um i believe
members
should place weight on in their planning
assessment of the application
chair and counselor armitage mentioned
first of all policies gs1 and gs6 and
housing supply
we have set out in the office report and
some detail
the views on those particular policies
and issues
and they are reflective of comments made
with
many numbers of appeals by planning
inspectors
and the issue is that
the presumption against new developed
outside
settlement development limits as set out
in our extant local plan
we're advised time and time again that
because of the
time scale of that plan and where we are
now our
ie nine plushers um in advance of that
that we can't rely purely and simply on
sites
lying outside settlement development
limits as a reason to refuse them
and that's because the national planning
policy frame which
as council shipments just said doesn't
place a presumption against new
development outside
urban areas and in countryside so i'd
ask members to be
very very careful and i'd urge
members not to resist the application
cooling simply
on the site's location outside the
settlement development limit and within
an area of countryside
just in terms again of the the issue
that council shipment made
about the development plan of the
emerging plan
yes you must determine this application
in accordance with the policies of your
development plan i
the 2001 2011 extant plan
that must be a starting point or less
material considerations or
indicate otherwise i've just outlined
specifically
why the policies and respect of
settlement limits
are not consistent with the framework
and therefore
i urge members to not place weight
on the fact that this site lies outside
a settlement limit and i'll come back to
other issues in a second if if you go
spare with me chair
the issue about the emerging plan that
council shipman
quite rightly makes the point is yes the
way to be attached to the policy of your
emerging plan
is for the decision maker ie planning
committee and that's for you to weigh
this afternoon all again i would urge is
that
inspectors are saying that on the issue
of housing generally
there are issues that aren't um
not with objection to the existing plan
the inspector is still to make a final
judgment on those issues
and therefore the council is in position
to adopt the plan
therefore i do urge members to be
careful in the weight you do attach to
your emerging planners officers
i sit out in the report we've advised
you place limited weight on the plan
but ultimately that's a matter for you
as a decision maker
just before i come on to policy to
anyone sharing the issue of heritage
assets i'd just like to
address again the issue that council
shipment raised with regards to
certainly the highway network and on the
highway issue as with all the technical
issues here
you'll see that there aren't any
technical issues set out by your
advisors by the the council tease to
refuse the application
and i've not heard evidence this
afternoon
that you can attach to any of those
technical considerations
to resist the application on that basis
again i'd urge
extreme caution and advise you against
having issues such as highway safety and
flooding
as determining factors in your
consideration
just on the issues that um i do believe
members um have discretion and can
attach weights they see fit to chair and
they they do relate as council armitage
rightly mentioned to the policy and
anyone in your extant local plan which
is
replicated by the emerging planned
policies and also
various policies in the mppf and that's
in relation
to the protection of the countryside not
for its own state necessarily but to
protect the character and appearance of
those
areas and again and coming back to
inspectors decisions weight has been
placed on
for example your policy any one which
seeks to protect the
character landscape character of
northeast derbyshire and
um in terms of mppf paragraphs 170
which talks about to recognize the
intrinsic
character and beauty of the countryside
and there's a general policy there to
conserve and enhance the countryside so
yes you can attach weight
to that issue and i'd ask you to and pay
particular
um attention to that and you'll need to
judge
whether you believe developed of this
site for housing
the extent that it is is detrimental and
would harm the character of the area
officers have concluded that harm
isn't overriding that is a view that you
do have to
take a view and come to a planning
judgement on
the second issue chair again counselor
armitage mentioned this
and that is the issue of the nearby
conservation area you are statutorily
required to pay special regard to that
in the setting of the conservation area
and if you feel that the conservation
area is harmed
i would say because the development
wouldn't obliterate the conservation
area you can't say it has
absolute harm so it's less than
substantial in mppf terms
what weight and what impact you think
that is and then your judgment has to be
do public benefits of the scheme
outweigh that harm and officers have
concluded that the public benefits
and generic benefits admittedly but um
additional housing and
all that that brings that is in this
case sufficient to override that harm
bearing in mind
the distinction that the development
site now has from the conservation area
and the way that officers believe it
could be designed but again
the um heritage issues is something that
members will need to take a view on it's
set out in the report in our
view as officers and we believe that
the public benefits does override the
lessons of
substantial harm in our opinion again
that's a matter for
um you and your colleagues chair in
making your decision this afternoon
thank you thank you are there any other
questions oh sorry chair
just one at one other point um council
achievement shipment also mentioned the
issue about
infrastructure particularly school
places and
it's also been raised in respect of
doctor surgeries and health care
you'll see from the consultation
responses the
requirement to address both of those
issues in absolute terms
and the nhs advisors have not requested
any 106 contributions
towards health provision or identified
enemy um
deficiency whereas with regards to
school places the county council have
specifically asked for
sums of money to address those issues
now whether those places are provided
out with the district in my opinion
isn't
um a matter that you should place
significant weight on it's just
addressing those shortfalls and again um
i'd urge caution on that issue
and you need to assess what evidence if
any you have
to show that that shortfall can't be met
and again
i would say that the responses you've
had from the council t
um consultants on that issue suggest
that shortfall can be met
and i would ask you to look very
carefully at that as well
thank you apologies for coming back in
thank you
are there any further questions issues
anyone wants to raise
no good
i'm just reading my notes um
all right having heard and read
everything today the officer's
recommendations before us which is the
view of committee on the application i'm
now opening the floor for the motions
i think we've had a mover in secondary
yeah
but it's not yet clear exactly what
grounds you wish to actually attach to
that
could i come in here certainly
as adrian has said uh
as far as i could see uh he says that
uh anyone uh the landscape
and he will have a detrimental effect
and that seems to be the strongest one
uh i still think that uh
be 11 uh it's next to a conservation
area
uh he seems to think that uh
the uh uh
what should i say the uh uh advantage of
this
uh site will outweigh uh
outweighs any detrimental effect to the
conservation area but
uh i don't think so uh
and i think that b11
still stands the sustainability well
that's certainly in in doubt and
he's urged caution uh about that
and also the fact that it's outside the
settlement development area the
open countryside he seems to
urge caution on that so
going forward i think it will be the
landscape
and the conservation area
the housing supply as far as i'm
concerned has been met
and uh it would be
detrimental to have more houses uh in
the on this side
so there you have it
is that effectively then um the issue
about
landscape proximity to the housing uh
sorry proximity to a conservation area
and the oversupply of housing is that
what you're saying yes
would uh council shipment agree with me
on it
yes i would i would i'll second that
i think we have to get if i could just
come back to
i think we have to be very careful on
technical things
like the highways because unless uh
we are we've got technical uh evidence
then it's uh very unsafe
come back to you adrian yes chair i
appreciate uh council robert's help on
those those issues chair um
as far as i um read it um the
the vote will be taken on um a concern
that the developed this site would have
an adverse impact on the landscape
character of the area that's contrary to
your local plant policy any one um and
also
the outline policies in the mppf
chair um if you would like we can add in
the
emerging policies that are similar in
those sorry the policies in your
emerging plan
that are similar to policy anyone
and also chair council armitage is is
saying and
from wrong council aren't you if you
will but you're saying that the
um public benefits in this case are
limited and don't outweigh the harm to
the character
of the conservationary hall field gate i
think it's all field
field gate conservation area and again
there are policies
chair and elements within the mppf
that could be added into that but again
you have similar policies in your
emerging plan with relation to heritage
assets which
again we can we can add in
yeah and finally chair if it's it's okay
with you
based on that framework um i would
suggest if members aren't minded to
refuse the application the final wording
is delegated to myself in consultation
with yourself and counselor barry as
vice chair
thank you councillor foster
thank you chair um
this this motion that's going to go
forward that's been put forward now
which looks to be put forward
um i've listened to those uh those
reasons for rejection that are
that have been put down let me suggested
could aging give us an opinion
on the strength of those and how they're
likely to stand up possibly
appeal thank you
um members will have heard me
say this before chair i'm afraid i've
i've given up trying to predict
appeal decisions um but what i would say
is that um we've two um
appeals that i know of of recently um
one that
was for um development of
over 200 houses at little morton road at
north wingfield
where argument in relation to landscape
character was successful
and the appeal was dismissed and thanks
largely to expert advice we got
landscape impact from someone we've
worked closely with a number of appeals
now
and more recently an appeal at sherland
not far from this site
um was allowed um on common lane at
sherland
so i think it will depend on um the
veracity of the argument
that can be put forward chair as
officers we've taken a view
um members in coming to a decision
um need to assess the two two elements
that we've talked about and
are framed in those draft reasons for
refusal
um in terms of appeal if you are minded
to refuse the application
we would need to support any appeal
with expert advice to support them
and the view that i would take is
if you are minded only to refuse the
application on those two grounds
they are arguable grounds that the
council
can defend so i don't think they are
unreasonable um
issues to refuse the application on but
i
can't guarantee um in the current state
of play with
regards to where the council's emerging
local planners i can't guarantee that
they would be successful but they are at
least
reasonable planning grounds on which you
could base the defense
i'm sorry i can't i can't give
councillor foster chair or yourselves
and guarantees on on how an appeal would
be um would be dealt with
i didn't i didn't need any uh i didn't
need that
but uh thanks for uh thanks for the
answer i appreciate that
thank you thank you
well if there's no further questions we
have a motion on the table so we'll go
to the vote
just to clarify the motion is to reject
officer recommendations for the ground
specified
in the meeting and
i'll leave members through the vote
we're going to be um doing a vote by
roll call
so i'll call your names in alphabetical
order if you could clearly say
for against or abstain
counselor william armitage for
carol huckabee
just i'm muting you counselor how could
be could you click on mute yes sorry
for counseling mo pots
or counselor alan powell
or councillor tracy reader
dane sorry could you just repeat that
counselor reader
abstain and stone
castle jackie ridgeway abstain
counselor kathy rouse dane
councillor diana rough
for roger answer
[Music]
with three abstentions and therefore the
motion is carried
thank you thank you everybody
and we can move on to the last item of
the agenda that's item
four matters of urgency
as i know there are no matters of
urgency
creature um you've missed the um
planning appeals lodge and determined
oh i do beg your pardons
if you'd like to take us through those
that's not on my agenda
following the um the large number that
members
saw at the last meeting chair and
this is quite a short report but members
will note that over the past
um week or so we've received a
significant number of appeals
um i hope members are still getting
those in your room
if you're finding an interesting reading
they they help in framing
decisions the way that they're arriving
at decisions but
you've achieved some considerable
success chair and that will be reflected
in the
gender item on this issue at your next
in meeting perhaps the the withdrawn
appeal which was a duplicate appeal
off the land at park avenue at tronfield
which you
may recall which subject to our
discussion at the last meeting chair
i'm happy to take any questions but it's
literally to say
in view of the um numbers that have come
in
subsequently but we are now seeing
something to be the backlog of
of covered impacted appeals come through
thank you are there any questions on
these
no thank you we'll move then to matters
of urgency
i have none as far as i'm aware there
aren't any
in which case i'll close the meeting and
i thank you all very much for today i
know it's been a long day
thank you hopefully we'll be back to
normality sooner rather than later
thank you and good afternoon
thank you
you